hey bonjour Comment ça va alors j'essaie
un nouveau type de format nouvel
environnement je vous prends un peu pour
un twitcher là on va dire
j'essaie de me mettre une lumière bleue
dans la gueule on va voir comment ça
rend juste une petite vidéo un peu
détente pour faire suite à la vidéo qui
est sorti il y a peu de temps sur la
chaîne là où je parlais de la
supériorité des économistes ou je
commentais un petit peu l'article de
algant Fourcade et au lion sur le fait
que les économistes citent très très peu
les sociologues alors que l'inverse
c'est un petit peu moins vrai parce que
il y a un article que j'aimerais vous
lire qui est publié qui a été publié en
fait là le 18 novembre donc très très
récemment sur le blog opinion de
alternative économique alors pourquoi je
vous lis un blog d'opinion ben c'est
parce que c'est un blog qui n'a pas été
écrit par n'importe qui il a été écrit
par
Eric Monnet donc je vous l'affiche là
c'est l'insoutenable légèreté les
économistes par Éric Monet le 18
novembre 2022 et Eric Monet c'est donc
un économiste mais pas n'importe quel
économiste un mec plutôt intéressant
déjà
parce que en 2022 il a été le lauréat de
du prix du meilleur jeune économiste
donc qui est un prix fondé par le monde
et le Cercle des économistes qui
récompense du coup des économistes qui
jugent talentueux et
Eric Monet il a un autre avantage c'est
que il travaille à le HS donc le HS en
plus j'en ai pas vraiment parlé dans ma
dernière vidéo c'est l'École des hautes
études en sciences sociales qui a quand
même le gros avantage d'être une école
pluridisciplinaire qui favorise une
approche conjointe entre plusieurs
branches de sciences sociales économie
sociologie sciences politiques et du
coup
Eric Monet il est économiste mais il a
plutôt une casquette d'historien de
l'économie d'ailleurs récemment il a il
a publié ce petit bouquin attends
j'essaie de faire le voilà donc la
banque Providence démocratiser les
banques centrales et la monnaie donc
c'est un spécialiste de finances de
d'économie monétaire mais surtout du
processus historique qui a mené à tout
ça il s'intéresse notamment aux solution
donc c'est un monsieur qui est très très
intéressant et donc il y a une dizaine
de jours il a publié sur la partie
opinion de du très bon magazine
alternatif économique un billet qui
revient sur le
nombreux problèmes en fait qui existent
dans la science économique et dans la
façon de faire de l'économie et qui en
fait qui sont des choses qui complètent
parfaitement la vidéo que j'ai fait
dernièrement qui va permettre d'aller
même un petit peu plus loin donc je me
proposais de vous en faire une lecture
en essayant de commenter un petit peu
quand ça s'y prête mais l'article assez
long donc déjà rien que faire une
lecture ce sera déjà pas mal et
du coup ça permettra dans un format un
peu plus détendu qui pour moi me demande
aussi un peu moins de montage mais qui
en termes d'apport au débat sur la
dernière vidéo ça permettra d'aller
quand même un peu plus loin et de
creuser grandement le sujet voilà je
vous propose qu'on traîne pas plus que
ça c'est parti pour ce petit numéro hors
série générique
[Musique]
donc l'insoutenable légèreté des
économistes par Éric Monet le 18
novembre 2022 il paraît que les
économistes deviennent de plus en plus
ouverts aux autres sciences sociales et
moins dépendants d'encadre théorique
unique la preuve en serait le tournant
empirique connaîtrait actuellement la
discipline la rendant plus proche des
données et des comportements économiques
et sociaux il est toujours difficile de
prendre position face à de telles
discours généraux qui se focalisent sur
certains économistes les plus en vue
plutôt qu'il ne reflètent la diversité
et les nuances d'une grande partie de la
recherche c'est sûr que si on regarde
uniquement les publications de Thomas
picetti on passe un petit peu en silence
une bonne partie de la production
économique si on s'attache toutefois aux
publications qui constituent la norme
dominante aujourd'hui en économie ce qui
est d'autant plus pertinent dans une
discipline connue pour fonctionner de
matière beaucoup plus hiérarchique
qu'aucune autre ça on l'a vu dans la
précédente vidéo il est permis de douter
de la réalité d'une telle ouverture et
certains exemples récents ne font que le
confirmer comme nous le verrons le
tournant
aucune nouveauté dans le fait que les
économistes s'aventurent sur des
terrains qui sont habituellement l'objet
d'autres disciplines et spécialités la
question est de savoir si cela se fait
dans un dialogue avec les autres savoirs
et donc en reconnaissant les limites des
méthodes de l'économie ou si l'aventure
prend en réalité la forme de
l'impérialisme avec la conviction que la
méthode des économistes est toujours
supérieure donc ça c'est un thème ultra
important qui a commencé dans les années
80 c'est ce qu'on appelle l'impérialisme
économique c'est-à-dire un moment où les
économistes ont commencé à dire mais en
fait avec notre méthode du calcul
rationnel pour avantage on peut
commencer à
[Musique]
vous avez fait entre trois facteurs
quelconque et des résultats économiques
dans cette perspective la démarche
scientifique vise à reproduire in vivo
l'expérience de laboratoire où l'on peut
distinguer aisément la différence de
résultat entre un groupe auquel on
admintre un traitement et un groupe
semblable qui n'est quant à lui pas
affecté donc ça c'est c'est vrai que
c'est c'est assez nouveau dans la
méthode économique ça a commencé un
petit peu avec son appel économie
expérimentale où on a commencé à faire
des tests en laboratoire en dire en
faisant des petits des petites
expériences on a testé par exemple
l'effet de la testostérone ah bah oui
effectivement on regarde que les les
personnes qui ont un niveau plus élevé
de testostérone ils ont tendance à avoir
des attitudes plus risquées aussi sur le
plan économique à en finance par exemple
etc donc en plein de petits résultats
comme ça mais qui peuvent être
difficilement généralisables et là un
des grands des grands changements qui a
vu la méthode c'est d'appliquer un petit
peu les méthodes qu'on voit en médecine
donc avec un groupe a un groupe a un
groupe B on met un place un peu comme si
on avait un groupe tous les mois à qui
on donne un placebo et un groupe test ou
dans laquelle on fait par exemple une
politique économique et on va tester
l'efficacité d'une politique une
polémique d'une politique économique oui
le chat tu laisses parler un petit peu
viens dire bonjour au moins et
typiquement ça c'est en France Esther
Duflot l'économiste est sert Duflot qui
est la portée standard de ce type de
méthode et qui a été largement avalisé
parce que elle est lauréate du prix
Nobel d'économie il y a deux ans
maintenant et la a été reçue sur sur
France Culture d'ailleurs il y a une
semaine pour parler justement elle elle
est spécialiste de la pauvreté et de
comment on se met en place une politique
efficace pour réduire la pauvreté et
elle utilise vraiment du coup des
méthodes d'évaluation des politiques
économiques qui sont
issus de la médecine pour essayer de
prouver du coup une implication causale
entre c'est bien cette politique
économique qui a permis de créer ce
résultat là et d'être la plus efficace
par exemple si on donne les
Mousquetaires les moustiquaires gratuite
quasiment plutôt que si on les fait
payer même un prix très modique c'est
beaucoup plus efficace pour lutter
contre le paludisme etc etc je reprends
les outils statistiques permettrait aux
économistes d’appliquer cette méthode en
dehors du laboratoire y compris à
l'histoire et à tout autre sujet et ça
le problème c'est quand on fait pas des
vrais expériences mais qu'on commence à
regarder dans l'histoire sans méthode là
encore il faudrait considérablement
nuancer ce constat mais il ne me semble
pas aberrant de dire que si pour
comprendre les canons de la discipline
tout économiste devait auparavant au
moins maîtriser les bases du calcul
rationnel il s'agit surtout aujourd'hui
de maîtriser les bases de
l'identification économétrique variable
instrumentale et méthodes des
différences de différence en particulier
oui donc la méthode des différences de
différence c'est ce qu'on appelle aussi
la méthode des doubles différences qui
est justement ce que je vous expliquais
tout à l'heure sur le fait d'essayer de
faire varier un seul facteur et du coup
de réussir à prouver que c'est bien ce
qu'on a fait varier qui donc produit
l'effet causal de par exemple la
politique économique on est en train de
tester
si les canons de la discipline ont
changé les rapports de l'économie
dominante aux autres disciplines n'ont
quant à eux pas évolué certains
économistes se considéraient supérieurs
auparavant car ils pensaient que seuls
les modèles formels d'individurationnels
pouvaient expliquer les comportements de
manière scientifique les autres
explications tenant de l'évaluation
subjective et non rigoureuse ouais on
est vraiment là-dedans c'est un peu le
personnage de caricatural que je faisais
dans ma vidéo en disant non mais attends
fais-moi des modèles d'équilibre
dynamique stochastique et après on
reparle parce que franchement qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire de l'entretien biographie
et des sondages enfin je veux dire ça
c'est des méthodes de babos en fait
c'est vraiment ça l'idée c'est qu'en
fait oui il nous faut des gros modèles
mathématisés économétriques mais en vrai
si on fait des méthodes plus
qualitatives basées sur des entretiens
de l'observation c'est des choses
subjectives c'est pas de la vraie
science et on va pas tomber sur des
vrais résultats donc en gros on
décidèrent complètement toutes les
autres méthodes
notamment de la sociologie
aujourd'hui les mêmes se considèrent
comme supérieur car ils pensent que les
autres sciences sociales ou tout autre
science plus généralement non pas les
outils adéquats pour parler de causalité
tout le reste n'est donc qu'anecdote
subjectivité qu'à particuliers sans
génération peut sans généralisation
possible ou corrélation trompeuses pour
reprendre les mots que les économistes
affectent pour décrier les autres
disciplines c'est exactement ce que je
vous disais la prétention des
économistes à la supériorité pour la
rationalité comme la causalité la force
des économistes est de produire des
critères unifiés et standardisés qui
deviennent une norme méthodologie dans
le monde entier ceci repose sur des
constructions théoriques fortes et d'une
grande cohérence cohérence interne aux
attraits intellectuelles évident et
souvent injustement caricaturé ou
sous-estimé par leurs critique je plaide
coupable c'est exactement ce que j'ai
fait dans ma précédente vidéo
complètement caricaturé ou sous-estimé
aussi certains raisonnements économiques
c'est pas parce que certaines hyp qui
sont irréalistes que tous les résultats
qui en sont issus sont sont
inintéressants et c'est ce que j'avais
essayé de faire d'ailleurs en modalisant
un petit peu ce que je racontais sur
Philippe agion
ça donne très très envie de le
caricaturer Philippe Aguillon mais il
faut pas non plus être au caricatural et
le il raconte quand même des choses qui
peuvent être ultra intéressantes
si tu te places dans son modèle de
validation beaucoup d'économistes n'ont
pas cette prétention et comprennent très
bien les limites de ces méthodes mais la
hiérarchie de la discipline survalorise
majoritairement ce qui ne s'embarrasse
pas de ces précaution et là on revient à
des problèmes justement d'organisation
de la vie scientifique la rationalité
comme la causalité sont des notions aux
définitions multiples et à l'histoire
très ancienne qui n'ont pas attendu les
économistes pour être théorisés les
logiciels et philosophes des sciences ne
cessent de nous le rappeler mais les
économistes dans les deux cas prétendent
avoir inventé la seule qui vaille ainsi
ce fameux tournant empirique actuel de
l'économie avec de plus en plus d'études
utilisant des données statistiques ne
gomme pour l'instant aucunement le
sentiment de sup sécurité vis-à-vis des
autres disciplines les mécanismes bien
connus et décrit notamment par Marion
fou Fourcade Etienne au lion et Yann
algant dans l'article de supérioritif of
Economist donc c'est précisément
l'article que on a discuté dans la
précédente vidéo ou plus récemment de
par Béatrice Cherrier dans un texte sur
les rapports de domination et les
récents scandales d'harcèlement sexuel
demeure à l'oeuvre je connaissais pas
les travaux de Béatrice charrier je suis
allé regarder très rapidement
effectivement elle a l'air de montrer
que qu'il y a des
pas mal de documentations de de de
d'agression sexistes dans les milieux
économistes alors en vrai c'est pas
vraiment étonnant parce que bon pas
vraiment étonnant déjà parce que le
sexisme il est partout en science comme
ailleurs mais dans un milieu comme on a
montré dans la précédente vidéo qui est
organisé de façon extrêmement
hiérarchisée
qui avec où on met en avant la
compétition des savoir-faire en plus
mathématiques qui sont montrés comme
davantage masculin donc un milieu en
plus lui-même très masculin c'est pas
étonnant qu'il y ait
une prévalence des agressions sexuelles
plus fortes peut-être que dans d'autres
disciplines d'ailleurs au passage je
vais en profiter pour vous montrer une
donnée que j'avais trouvé assez
intéressante de l'article de Fourcade
algant et aux lions mais que j'avais pas
vraiment réussi à trouver comment
l'insérer dans la vidéo c'est
le taux donc le pourcentage de de test
de doctorat qui sont passés par des
femmes dans les différentes disciplines
entre 1966 et 2011 alors comme on voit
ici bon dans les années 60 sans trop de
surprises il y avait très peu de femmes
qui avaient des thèses quelle que soit
la discipline mais on regarde que ça a
beaucoup évolué mais en gardant 2010 en
psychologie c'est majoritairement des
femmes 70% des thèses de psychologie
soutenus sont le sont par des femmes en
sociologie on est pas mal aussi si on
est entre 55 et 60% des thèses en
sociologie qui sont maintenus par qui
sont va passer par des femmes alors que
regardez on voit qu'en sciences éc
dynamique on est on est très très bas on
est à moins de 30% je dirais 28% à peu
près des thèses d'économie qui sont
soutenues par des femmes en fait on est
très très proche de la physique et en
fait la physique c'est une des sciences
en fait les moins féminisées qui
existent parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
stéréotypes qui pèsent aussi sur la
physique donc on voit que
les l'économie a toujours essayé de
prouver que c'est une vraie science
qu'utilise des vrais méthodes
scientifiques en prenant exemple
notamment sur la physique et on voit
qu'en fait cette prise d'exemple elle se
retrouve aussi même dans le public qui
qui qui
fait ce genre de formation puisque on a
très peu de femmes finalement qui
passent des tests d'économie et ce qui
peut être évidemment un signe de de type
de valeur qui peuvent qui peuvent
circuler et donc de ne pas rendre très
très étonnant les accusations sexisme
qui pourraient avoir peser sur ce milieu
là je reprends
les économistes citent rarement les
autres disciplines et même quand ils le
font ils ne semblent pas les lire ce
qu'on a vu dans la précédente vidéo
quand il les lisent c'est pour épuiser
des données ou des exemples hors
contexte capable d'illustrer leur thèse
plutôt que pour comprendre l'intérêt
d'une démarche scientifique qui ne pose
pas les mêmes questions et utilise
d'autres méthodes aux critères
scientifiques différents mais non moins
rigoureux une des conséquences est la
survalorisation de certains critères
scientifiques par ailleurs effectivement
important qui contraste avec la
négligence d'autres pourtant essentiels
à toute démarche prétendant faire
science
ce traverse se manifeste
particulièrement lorsque les économistes
aventurent sur les terrains dont ils ne
sont pas familiers et c'est pourquoi le
rapport de l'économie aux autres
disciplines est particulièrement
révélateur de ces problèmes structurels
selon préambule n'avait pour seul but
que d'expliquer comment la discipline
économique peut à la fois porter très
haut des revendications à la supériorité
scientifique tout en produisant
certaines aberrations qui ne pourront
qu’étonner les personnes non familières
de la recherche en économie venons-en
donc à ses aberrations et oui parce que
tout ça ce qu'on disait depuis tout à
l'heure c'était juste l'introduction
donc on est parti pour le fond du propos
et là on est parti
des chiffres bidons de population un
exemple récent illustre particulièrement
bien selon moi les problèmes de
l'économie aujourd'hui des historiens
avaient depuis une dizaine d'années elle
a alerté à plusieurs reprises sur
l'utilisation de fausses données
historique de population par des
économistes dont les travaux font
pourtant référence et se tissu au sommet
de la pyramide hiérarchique de la que la
profession affectionne publication dans
les meilleures revues dites top 5
milliers de citations postes de
professeurs dans les universités
prestigieuses aux États-Unis en
particulier Harvard et anity un article
de timothyan apparaître dans le journal
économic is story fait enfin le point
sur ses erreurs et montre de manière
systématique l'ampleur du problème on
peut jeter un petit coup d'oeil à
l'article we do not no the population of
everyton free in the world for the pass
to season years donc voilà on ne le
titre de l'article c'est on ne connaît
pas la population de chaque pays dans le
monde pour les deux derniers millénaires
et justement donc c'est important parce
que il va revenir sur le fait que les
économistes parfois utilisent ces
données là alors que il y a aucune
fiabilité là-dessus on y revient
l'affaire n'est pas bénigne car elle ne
concerne pas des erreurs marginales et
reconnues par des auteurs oublient
temporaire différence d'interprétations
ou de controverses scientifique qui sont
la normalité du processus scientifique
rappelons en effet si les besoins que
l'erreur fait partie de la science et la
reconnaissance de l'erreur est un
élément fondamental de la recherche
scientifique il n'y a pas de chercheur
qui ne se soit jamais trompé et ça c'est
très important de l'avoir en tête c'est
le problème c'est pas tant de faire des
erreurs que de rester sur ces erreurs de
pas reconnaître ses erreurs de pas
confronter
les différentes
interprétations sur un même jeu de
données ou de pas retirer un article qui
aurait dont on aurait prouvé
la démarche fautive mais ce n'est pas de
cela dont il s'agit ici le problème
concerne l'utilisation
plusieurs articles d'économie devenus
très influents de donner historiques qui
ne reposent sur aucune sinon l'invention
des auteurs ces articles appartiennent
tous à un courant de recherche
particulièrement populaire qui vise à
appliquer la démarche d'identification
causale similaire à l'expérience de
laboratoire à l'évolution économique sur
plusieurs siècles et à travers tous les
continents donc un peu comme si on
essayait de faire
la méthode des doubles différences en
regardant l'effet d'une politique
économique surdopulation équivalent sauf
que au lieu de faire vraiment
l'expérience on la reconstitue à partir
de données historiques
le problème c'est que si les données
historiques sont fausses
voilà
donc et à travers tous les continents à
des sujets aussi divers que les effets
de la religion de la transition
démographique le colonialisme
l'esclavage ou les institutions
politiques sur l'économie les données de
population ils sont principalement
utilisés pour comparer le développement
économique des pays au cours de
plusieurs siècles les données utilisées
par les économistes sont tirés d'un
livre publié en 1978 alors déjà
quand ça commence à faire 30 40 ans que
tes données sont là bon par Coline MC FD
Coline mckedy et Richard Jones atlas of
world population history qui présentait
les statistiques de population sur 2000
ans classés par pays suivant la
définition des frontières de la fin des
années 70 ce qui peut poser problème les
frontières évidemment en 2000 ans elles
ont bougé cet ouvrage avait été écrit
pour le grand public comme d'autres
rédigés par le psychiatre Colin mcvy qui
s'était passionné pour l'histoire en
particulier sur la période de la période
médiévale en dépit de leur amateurisme
les auteurs semblaient avoir l'intention
de ne pas seulement toucher le grand
public mais d'en faire un livre de
référence point de départ à d'autres
études plus rigoureuses et fouillées
cela ne les empêchait pas de reconnaître
clairement qu'une grande partie de leur
donner était inventée faute de mieux
c'est une citation traduction de de
Eric Monet nous ne tenterons pas de
dissimuler la nature hypothétique de
notre traitement des périodes
antérieures traduit il traduit
leur justification principale était que
les limites supérieures et inférieures
imposées par le bon sens sont souvent
beaucoup plus proches l'une de l'autre
que l'on ne pourrait le croire le livre
de macvy et Jones reconnaissait que les
données de population était la plupart
du temps indisponible avant le 19e
siècle cela d'autant plus hors d'Europe
ou les recensements ils ne commencent
qu'au 10/8 siècle il proposait donc
d'inventer des données pour un grand
nombre de ces pays en se fondant sur la
simple perception par les auteurs le
fameux bon sens dont je reparlerai
peut-être un jour de la taille d'un pays
ou du nerf géographique à telle ou telle
période c'est le cas notamment pour la
quasi-totalité des pays africains bon
bah au moins c'est clair qui ont reçu la
tension particulière des économistes
étudiant les effets de l'esclavage et du
colonialisme dans certains pays dans
certains cas pardon les auteurs se
fondaient sur des estimations de
démographes ou d'historiens mais sans
justifier leur choix ni rendre compte du
fait que les estimations disponibles
étaient très incertaine et pouvait
varier très fort au moins entre 1 et 5
pour l'Inde par exemple comme le
mentionnel John Durand dans sa critique
entre 1 et 5 c'est quand même beaucoup
beaucoup
n'ayant pas plus d'idées sur le niveau
de la population que sur son taux de
croissance macvy et Jones appliquait la
plupart du temps une croissance
similaire partielle pour un pays donné
supposant par exemple que l'Autriche
gagne 250 000 habitants tous les 50 ans
au 17e siècle à 18e siècle parce que
pourquoi pas comme le montre Guinan donc
l'article cité au début ils
arrondissaient les chiffres
systématiquement en fonction d'une règle
qui dépend de la taille de la population
créant donc un autre type d'erreur
systématique il ne fait aucun doute que
les deux auteurs ont dû s'amuser à
inventer au doigt mouillé la population
de l'ensemble des pays sur deux
millénaires en fonction de leur
présupposés sur l'histoire du monde et
son évolution il est moins drôle que des
économistes et puis penser qu'il
s'agissait là d'une source fiable ça
c'est un vrai problème quand
là on a visiblement des gens qui avaient
des préventions sur sur la population
des pays concret pour inventer du coup
des données et un bouquin visant qui ont
qui n'ont fait que confirmer ces
précautions forcément parce que ça se
passe sur rien et qu'on utilise
maintenant pour valider ses précautions
c'est quelque chose qu'on voit beaucoup
aussi quand notamment quand on parle de
sexisme dans l'histoire
des discours qui visent à
essentialiser les rapports de genre avec
une validation de type oui mais ça
remonte aux hommes préhistoriques c'est
normal l'homme c'est un chasseur alors
que la femme elle s'occupait des enfants
sans s'apercevoir qu'en fait en faisant
en fait on n'en sait rien personne
n'était là autant des hommes
préhistoriques personne peut vérifier
qu'elle était l'organisation des hommes
préhistoriques déjà en plus les hommes
préhistoriques ça veut rien dire on
parle de de population humaine qui
vivent sur tout le blog tout le globe
pendant des centaines de milliers
d'années donc qui qu'une seule
organisation sociale c'est complètement
impossible et en fait ce qu'on fait en
disant l'homme chassé et la femme
s'occuper des enfants c'est qu'on ne
fait que projeter
propre stéréotypes d'aujourd'hui sur des
sur des sociétés passées et qu'on va
utiliser ça pour du coup essayer de de
justifier le sexisme la société
d'aujourd'hui sauf qu'en fait bah
l'argument tient pas c'est le serpent
qui se mord la queue on valide un
argument par lui-même quoi c'est le
sexisme existe parce que c'est le
sexisme bon
lors de sa parution en 1978 l'ouvrage
n'avait pas été considéré comme une
publication scientifique il n'a jamais
été traduit il ne fut pas considéré
comme un ouvrage de référence et on
compte très peu de compte-rendus dans
les revues universitaires les
quelques-unes que l'on peut trouver sont
très critiques et témoignent de
l'embarras des spécialistes face à des
données dont il est strictement
impossible d'évaluer le degré
d’approximation ou d'invention outre
celui de Gilles durant précédemment cité
voir celui très court dans population la
revue de l'Inde qui conclut
lapidairement et sarcastiquement
sarcastiquement aucune évaluation
contradictoire permettant de juger le
degré d'approximation des données
avancées les citer ouais donc en gros
ils ont fait un bouquin de population et
la source c'est inquiète
la légèreté des statistiques des
économes là légèreté statistique des
économistes on y apprend aussi que même
lorsque certaines estimations de
population avaient été construites par
des spécialistes makafdi et Jones
faisaient souvent l'impasse dessus
l'historien arrête Austin qui dénonçait
de 2008 la légèreté avec laquelle les
économistes traitent des données
historiques y compris mais non seulement
celle sur la population remarquer avec
ironie que la bibliothèque de la Landon
School a fait conamix où il enseignait
n'avait jamais à qui l'ouvrage de Makie
et Jones avant que des économistes
influents commencent à l'utiliser
abondamment cet ouvrage de l'épis des
années 2000 ouais donc en fait on avait
un ouvrage qui parlait de population qui
était complètement
qui qui était complètement passé sous le
radar aucune revue perd tout le monde
s'en fout tous les démographes disaient
de la merde et puis les économistes on
sait pas pourquoi comment ça l'utiliser
et parce que les économistes l'utilisent
on le voit apparaître dans les
bibliothèques mais du coup jamais
utilisé par des personnes qui s'y
connaissent
population en démographie ou en
géographie donc
au calme aujourd'hui si on regarde sur
Google Scholar les principales
publications du site le livre de bac
fdjones sont l’œuvre d'économiste depuis
une vingtaine d'années voilà ce que je
vous disais à quelques exceptions les
historiens ou démographes se sont tenus
écartés de cette étrange objet où l'on
utilisait de manière sporadique et
critique l'utilisation systématique de
ces données comme si elles étaient
vraies et bien l'apanage des économistes
en gros voilà les économies qui
utilisent ça comme si c'était vrai sans
jamais
justifié quoi que ce soit dans son
article Guinan démontre les
justifications de certains économistes
qui prétendent qu'ils serviraient là de
simples erreurs de mesures aléatoires
qui pourraient se compenser entre elles
la méthode baroque utilisée par makevd
et Jones de l'invention de données à
leur arrondi en passant par la
recomposition de pays dans des
frontières actuelles créent
nécessairement des erreurs de mesure
systématique on peut d'ailleurs
s'étonner de l'utilisation de l'argument
sur les erreurs de mesure aléatoires
dans un tel cas il pourrait servir à
justifier toute l'invention de données
puisqu'il est par nature impossible
d'estimer l'erreur d'une donnée inventée
oui parce que ça ça a un grand truc chez
les chez les économistes l'idée que en
fait c'est pas très grave si on a des
modèles qui sont faux du moment que les
les que en moyenne les erreurs se
compensent l'idée c'est une idée qui est
très importante pour
pour justifier de l'utilisation aussi
générale du modèle de de décision
rationnelle c'est on considère que les
individus sont en moyenne rationnel
parce qu'en fait c'est vrai que
finalement quand on prend nos décisions
économiques on n'est pas six éloignés de
la rationalité et en fait les économies
je sais très bien que les économistes
nous disent je sais très bien que en
vrai dans la vraie vie véritable les
gens ils sont pas complètement
rationnels mais en fait les billets de
rationalités ils sont pas toujours dans
dans le même sens en fait ils peuvent
être rationnels vers le haut vers le bas
disons que par exemple pour être
parfaitement rationnel il faudrait que
j'ai parlé telle somme tous les mois et
ben en fait il y a des gens qui vont
épargner plus et il y a des gens qui
vont épargner moins et donc du coup
comme on est comme les gens sont en
moyenne rationnel et qu'il y a des gens
qui sont au-dessus de la rationalité
d'autres qui sont en dessous en moyenne
ça se compense les billets se compense
et donc du coup c'est pas grave de faire
de postuler quand on étudie des grandes
populations de postuler quand même la
rationalité parce que les billets ce
qu'on pense entre eux c'est pas absurde
comme façon de voir et surtout ça permet
quand même de de montrer des choses
le problème c'est que là dans ce qu'on
nous montre c'est pas du tout comme si
c'était des erreurs aléatoires qui du
pour eux du coup pourrait se compenser
puisque les gens ont carrément inventé
des données et ils ont pas fait des
erreurs aléatoires ils ont fait des
erreurs systématiques c'est à dire que
par exemple pour certains pays ils ont
eu tendance à systématiquement
surestimer dans tel condition ou à
l'inverse d'autres pays a complètement
systématiquement sous-estimé quand on
était dans telle configuration donc
c'est pas du tout le genre d'erreur
d'approximation qui peut se compenser
parce que on étudie plein de pays en
même temps
comment peut-on donc je reprends comment
peut-on expliquer l'utilisation
abondante et influente de fausses
données de population par des
économistes des universités les plus
prestigieuses au monde et la publication
de ces travaux dans des revues
considérées comme les meilleurs en
pratiquant une évaluation par les pairs
pourquoi seulement des économistes ont
pu s'embarquer dans ce naufrage alors
que beaucoup d'autres sciences sociales
auraient potentiellement été séduites
par ces données comment cette pratique a
pu durer plus de 20 ans et des sans
doute pas terminé aucun retrait
d'article n'est à ma connaissance en
cours alors ça c'est une vraie bonne
question finalement pourquoi c'est chez
les économistes qu'on retrouve de telles
dérives scientifiques et ben on devait
on est parti pour la dernière ou la
dernière partie mépris des autres
sciences sociales et refus de la
critique cela me paraît symptomatique de
deux problèmes importants de l'économie
d'aujourd'hui il s'agit tout d'abord du
sentiment de supériorité de la
profession face aux autres disciplines
c'est ce qu'on montrait dans la vidéo
précédente les travaux qui utilisent les
données de Mac FD Jones ont en effet en
commun de se prétendre
interdisciplinaire et d'étudier
l'histoire du monde sur plusieurs
siècles à partir de méthodes
d'identification causales des
économistes donc oui oui on fait de la
méthode pluridisciplinaire mais en fait
j'ai dit bonjour qui tu dis bonjour à
YouTube
on est reparti donc il prétendait
éclairer des questions abordées en
histoire ou sciences politiques en
particulier la construction de l'État
les effets du colonialisme l'évolution
des inégalités ou de la démographie
démographies sans te dire compte des
apports des autres sciences sociales
donc oui c'est exactement ce que vous
disais ils disent genre oui on va faire
de la pluridisciplinarité mais en fait
ils utilisent juste leur méthode sur
d'autres données sans du tout lire ce
qui s'est fait ailleurs certains de ces
auteurs ont par ailleurs écrit
explicitement que leur but était ainsi
de rendre l'histoire économique
véritablement scientifique en opposition
aux méthodes des historiens voilà on
fait de l'histoire mieux que les
historiens quoi
ce sentiment supériorité méthodologique
qui conduit à penser que face à d'autres
sciences considérées comme incapables de
maîtriser les techniques quantitatives
et le raisonnement causal il est
toujours préférable d'utiliser les
statistiques même fausses deuxièmement
cette affaire montre comment la critique
est étouffée en économie et ça on en
parlait dans la dernière vidéo justement
quand on avait vu le graphe qui montrait
en quoi le débat avait complètement
déserté les grandes revues d'économie
c'est l'idée que bah c'est l'économie
est devenue tellement hiérarchiser et
c'est devenu tellement quelque chose
dont tout le monde est aux ordres devant
les grandes revues et les patrons des
grandes associations d'économistes
que
en fait on a pas de voix dissidente donc
pas d'hétérodoxe et quand il y a des
gens qui disent ouais mais cet article
méthodologiquement il est quand même un
peu tout pourri ben en fait complètement
étouffé on peut pas le discuter et c'est
pour ça qu'il y a pas de retrait
d'article en fait c'est parce que il y a
plus de discussion dans les grandes
revues même la critique interne c'est à
dire celle qui porte sur l'utilisation
des méthodes standards et relativement
peu commune et
les commentaires critiquent d'articles
publiés sont rares et les retards
d'articles ayant été démontrés comme
faux sont quasi inexistants ça c'est
plutôt grave alors même que la
discipline souffre comme beaucoup
d'autres de forts problèmes de
réplication des résultats oui d’ailleurs
à ce propos je vous conseille une vidéo
ultra intéressante de science étonnantes
qui avait discuté justement de ça d'un
article ultra célèbre en économie de
Reinhardt et Rogoff qui avait montré
avec leurs données que donc l'argument
c'était que les en gros c'est un article
qui visait à montrer que la dette
publique c'est pas bien et qui montrait
quand il y avait une corrélation très
forte entre le taux d'endettement des
pays et
et le taux de croissance une corrélation
négative ce qui fait que les pays qui
étaient les plus endettés
avaient des taux de croissance plus
faibles et surtout qu'il y avait un
effet de seuil très très fort dans le
sens où à partir du moment où on
dépassait 90% de dettes publiques enfin
80% du PIB en dette publique
on commence à avoir des effets délétères
sur la croissance
et cet article il a été beaucoup cité
publié dans une grande revue
prestigieuse il a eu énormément d'effets
politiques c'est-à-dire que il y a plein
de politiques économiques qui sont
lancées à la suite de certains clans en
disant ah bah en fait la dette publique
c'est pas bien il faut surtout pas
dépasser le seuil fatidique des 90 %
d'être sur PIB et en fait on s'est
aperçu plus tard que les données de
l'article étaient complètement bidonnées
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait les
quand on a essayé de répliquer les
résultats il y a
en fait on n'arrivait pas à retrouver
les mêmes résultats et en fait on s'est
aperçu qu'ils ont fait des erreurs de
manipulation de débutants sur Excel pas
sélectionné la moitié des données ou à
faire des regroupements qui avaient pas
de sens et que et qu'en fait l'article
est juste faux et que quand on recalcule
les données non seulement on voit on
voit que le lien entre
faible croissance et d'être sur PIB il
est pas si fort que ça et surtout qu'il
y a pas du tout d'effets de seuil donc
du coup cette croyance des 90% de dette
sur PIB elle est complètement fausse et
évidemment ce qu'il faut bien avoir en
tête c'est que
l'article qui disait qu'il faut pas
dépasser les 90% d'être sur PIB eu
beaucoup plus de bruit et d'effets
politiques que évidemment les débunkages
de l'article qui ont été fait ensuite
parce que il y a eu des publications
pour le coup pour montrer que l'article
était faux mais l'article à ma
connaissance il a jamais été retiré non
plus
il y a enfin il y a pas eu de retrait
d'articles et et et les auteurs
considèrent continuent même de de
réfuter que ils se sont trompés donc un
vrai gros problème de de d'admettre ces
erreurs quoi alors je commence à avoir
plus de batterie donc je dois changer ma
batterie et on reprend juste après ça
hello j'ai changé ma batterie on est
reparti donc tout ça pour vous dire oui
à propos des articles économiques qui
sont pas qui sont pas retirés même quand
il y a des preuves évidentes que les
données sont complètement bidonnées
allez voir la vidéo de science étonnante
pour sur le sujet pour le coup elle est
elle est vraiment très bien faite
physicien j'ai envie de dire
chaton
les chatons c'est mignon mais c'est un
peu chiant quand même quand ça fait du
bruit
on est reparti
la contestation des méthodes des
économistes à partir du point de vue des
autres disciplines et quant à elle
presque systématiquement t'écarter outre
Garrett Austin si tu es précédemment
plusieurs autres historiens ou même
économistes ont rapidement alerté les
économies sur les aberrations des
données de ma FD et Jones comme nous le
rappelle ginan ce n'est pas un cas isolé
et on peut même dire que le fait de ne
pas se confronter à des critiques
externes et la norme c'est ainsi par
exemple que les paradigmes différents
continuent d'exister toutefois de moins
en moins mais sans que le paradigme
dominant se confronte aux autres les
critiques des autres disciplines n'en
sont pas pour ne sont les critiques des
autres disciplines ne sont pas mieux
prises en compte et c'est cela n'est pas
réservé aux sciences sociales les
critiques des biologistes voire ici et
là donc là il met des liens vous irez
voir si vous voulez ou des
anthropologues vis-à-vis des récents
arguments génétiques fallacieux certains
économistes n'ont pas empêché ceci de se
répandre au sein de la discipline un
article de harcha fait Galore publié
dans American économic review en 2013
particulièrement incriminée réussie l'ex
de combiner des données génétiques
douteuses aux statistiques de population
macf diet Jones c'est un bingo un autre
exemple malheureusement bien connu
concerne les nombreuses critiques
adressées par des juristes et des
historiens à des études très influentes
d'économistes portant sur les effets des
régimes juridiques sur le développement
économique et financier au cours de
l'histoire les thèses des économistes
ont beau être démenti par les faits et
par les spécialistes des autres
disciplines les économistes portant ces
thèses ne connaissant ni droit ni
l'histoire elle continue d'être
présentée comme vrai par ces derniers
comme si les critiques n'existaient pas
et qu'il n'était pas nécessaire de s'y
confronter c'est exactement ce que je
vous disais pour l'article de Reinhart
et Rogoff c'est à dire que même si on a
prouvé que les données étaient bidonnées
et que tout que rien n'allait dans cet
article il continue à le défendre et
ils n'ont pas retiré de la Revue
économique des pratiques éloignées de la
rigueur scientifique une des
conséquences de ces problèmes que montre
bien l'utilisation des données de makevt
et Jones
on incite aujourd'hui les chercheurs à
formuler de grandes thèses démontrant la
supériorité méthodologique des
économistes à partir d'identification
causale plutôt que de fournir un travail
rigoureux et apparemment plus modeste
sur les données comme le rappelle Guinan
un énorme travail reste à effectuer et
est impossible pour reconstruire des
données de population plus fiables pour
certains pays mais ce type de recherche
est actuellement beaucoup moins valorisé
il semble préférable pour faire carrière
de montrer ses muscles méthodologiques
et d'ignorer les critiques et ses
erreurs le statisticien Andrew Gelman
parvenait à un constat similaire dans un
texte cherchant à comprendre comment une
revue d'Économie avait pu publier
l'article d'achat fait Galore mentionné
ci-dessus c'est donc bien un problème
structurel de la discipline déjà maintes
fois pointée du doigt qui est ici mise
en lumière le jugement pour apparaître
sévère mais l'effet sont têtus le
sentiment de supériorité méthodologique
encore trop souvent présent chez les
économistes ne crée pas seulement des
œillères il justifie la persistance de
pratique bien éloigné de la rigueur
scientifique cela ne veut pas dire que
la situation est beaucoup plus rose
ailleurs mais le constat est
suffisamment inquiétant pour ne pas
penser qu'il soit superflu de donner
plus de place à la critique et à la
reconnaissance de méthodologie diverses
et de la porte des autres disciplines
merci
Eric Monet voilà donc un petit un
article assez long quand même assez
assez touffu mais qui montre qui qui
a un assez bon complément à la vidéo
qu'on avait fait précédemment sur la
supériorité des économistes c'est de
montrer en quoi ce sentiment supériorité
sur les méthodes il a tendance enfin il
pose des vrais problèmes scientifiques
parce que il amène les économistes à
être trop sur deux et à pas se poser de
questions à se dire qu'ils sont
tellement par nature par l'utilisation
de leur méthode supérieure aux méthodes
des historiens des sociologues des
anthropologues etc que il
ne remettent pas leur propre méthode en
cause leurs propres biais en cause et ça
ne leur vient même pas à l'idée que il
n'aurait pas la capacité eux-mêmes à
juger de la pertinence
scientifique d'un travail d'historien ou
de sociologue qu'il se réapproprierait
pour eux-mêmes et du coup même quand on
a des économistes qui enfin font des
petites incursions dans d'autres
disciplines pour citer les travaux en
fait comme ils sont comme ils
connaissent pas les autres méthodes et
qu'ils ont pas capables d'en évaluer de
la pertinence bah du coup ils prennent
des travaux de merde et ils sites de la
merde et et après il utilise de il
utilise pour faire des travaux de merde
et comme c'est un tout petit monde très
archés ça se retrouve dans des très
grandes revues qui ne sont pas discutées
et quand on arrive enfin parce que il y
a un article de discussion qui est passé
approuvé qu'un article est mauvais ben
il est pas retiré des revues parce que
c'est un tout petit monde très organisé
de cette façon là donc ça veut ça veut
pas forcément dire qu'il y a que que
c'est forcément plus plus vert dans
toutes les autres disciplines dans la
mesure où
il y a as je crois à ma connaissance
pour le coup loin d'être spécialistes
mais je crois qu'il y a assez peu
d'articles qui ont été retirés en
sociologie aussi quand il y a des
canulars par exemple comme ça arrive
parfois évidemment qui sont retirés mais
des rétractions d'articles
ça doit pas être extrêmement fréquent
mais par contre en sociologie il a
discussion d'articles en fait il y a des
artistes des articles qui s'ils sont pas
retirés ont été tellement discutés en
mal que finalement ils peuvent
être cité uniquement comme repoussoir ou
comme modèle de ce qu'il faut pas faire
voilà et ben écoutez j'espère que ça
vous aura plu que ça vous aura intéressé
je vous invite à aller si vous ne le
connaissez pas découvrir un petit peu ce
que ce qui est écrit Eric Monet il a
plusieurs billets de blog comme ça sur
sur le site de alternative économique
son petit bouquin bon Providence alors
je vais être tout à fait honnête avec
vous je n'ai pas encore lu c'est c'est
il est sur ma pile mais je l'ai pas
encore terminé par contre j'ai souvent
du coup du fait qu'il a gagné le prix du
meilleur jeune économiste de France en
2022 ou enfin pas de France de
meilleures années économiste en 2022 il
a été pas mal reçu dans les médias donc
il a été reçu bah il a même été reçu un
quotidien d'ailleurs mais il était reçu
à France Culture et évidemment il a été
reçu ogeco et donc du coup je l'ai quand
même pas mal écouté parler donc je sais
à peu près ce qui raconte sur sur les
banques centrales même si j'ai la femme
en train de lire son petit bouquin qui a
l'air qu'elle a vraiment passionnant et
d'ailleurs si la question des des
banques centrales vous intéresse il y a
eu une table ronde
ogeco sur l'indépendance des banques
centrales en présence d'Éric Monet il y
avait aussi Laurence slalom très très
grande économiste aussi passionnante et
et leur discussion est vraiment vraiment
super intéressante je vous invite à
aller voir ça de toute façon à peu près
tout ce qui s'est fait où gecko était
quand même assez passionnant et puis on
a la chance maintenant accès à tout en
replay donc on aurait tort de se priver
sinon je crois que je vais en rester là
ça me fait très plaisir de passer ce
moment avec vous je vous fais des gros
bisous et à bientôt Ciao